hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast plant viruses everywhere in
Austin Mitchell lipstick
I'm Christina jewel of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented and
sponsored by lab leaves the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning for more information please
visit www.sap.com/learnbi for we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit these questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of your presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner this white
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button on
the lower left this is an educational
webinar and that offered free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on that CTE button
located at the bottom left-hand corner
of the web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker
Marilyn Rosen PhD Marilyn Richmond is
professor of Plant Pathology and
environmental microbiology and biology
at the Center for infectious disease
dynamics at Pennsylvania State
University dr. Ruth pink received a PhD
in 1986 from the University of Colorado
School of Medicine in microbiology and
immunology studying hepatitis B virus on
the National Institutes of Health
fellowship
following a postdoctoral fellowship at
Cornell University where she began
studying plant viruses she moved to the
Samuel Roberts Noble Foundation as the
principal investigator then focused her
research on plant virus evolution and
ecology after the discovery of a novel
plants fungus virus three-way
mutualistic symbiosis that allows plants
to grow in jail and thermal soils in
Yellowstone National Park her interest
expanded to include viruses of Bunji
currently she's a member of the center
of infectious disease dynamics any
professor of virus ecology in the
Department of Plant Pathology and
environmental microbiology at the
Pennsylvania State University she and
her team have been studying virus
ecology and experimental evolution for
25 years using plant and fungal viruses
as models and have published a number of
seminal papers in this area
she was an expert in virus diversity and
biodiversity and has done extensive work
on complex interactions between
beneficial viruses and their hosts that
are involved in adaptation of plants and
Sunday to extreme environments I will
now turn it over to Maryland for no
presentation dr. Issie thank you very
much thank you very much for the
introduction so I'm just gonna start
right off with my slides and I want to
acknowledge some people that are on the
first slide here so the title of the
talk is plant viruses everywhere and
often new allistic and I wanted to
acknowledge a down bow release Marquez
purse and Jeet Saha and ping Shu who are
have been very instrumental in this work
and some of the work I'm going to talk
about today I'm going to give you kind
of a ten year time span on this so some
of it started at the Nobel foundation
where I used to be and then we continued
it here at Penn State so I want to
introduce the topic of our C ecology
first of all because most of us who are
biologists
kind of grew up with a reductionist new
point of molecular biology and that
involves a lot of experimental work and
it's been very important and it's taught
us a lot about viruses but most of this
has focused on human related viruses
which means viruses and humans and in
domestic animals and plants but now as
I've gotten older in my career I decided
to take a broader picture and so one of
the things we've been doing is looking
at viruses in wild hosts and also we
look at how viruses really affect the
interaction between the host and the
larger environment so we've backed away
from this reductionist view point to try
to see what's really going on in the
real world and the real environment so I
also want to introduce you to this
concept of viruses as symbionts we in
our lab we use the classic definition of
symbiosis which was coined in the 19th
century and it was basically people
working on lichen and they discovered
like and they discovered two dissimilar
entities and algae and a fungus that
we're living together in a symbiotic
relationship and that's essentially the
definition two or more dissimilar
entities living in or on one another in
an intimate relationship so if you are a
symbiont
you have different lifestyle choices you
could be mutualistic and people often
confuse mutualism with symbiosis but
that's just one kind of symbiosis
so Santos's can also be commensal or
antagonistic so it does not mean
mutualism antagonistic commensal and
mutualistic symbiosis are on something
of a continuum also so entities that are
symbiotic can move around this sometimes
they may be mutualistic sometimes they
may become in Soul that can depend on
the environment so antagonistic
symbiosis means that the city osis is
detrimental to one partner while the
other is benefited and this includes
most of the viruses you heard about
these are the viruses that cause disease
in humans and in livestock and plants
and wildlife and these are very well
studied but in fact these interactions
are probably
very common when we look at the big
world of biology so commensal symbiosis
is when the relationship is neutral for
one or both partners and this is
probably the most common virus host
interaction mutualistic excuse me
mutualistic symbiosis is when the
relationship is beneficial for all the
partners and I should point out here
that symbiosis doesn't mean just two
partners it can be more than two and
there are many examples of these
mutualistic symbiosis relationships in
viruses but they are very poorly studied
so some of these relationships are
obligate that means that the virus is
required for the survival of its host
and some are conditional so depending on
the conditions the virus may or may not
be required and I'll talk about both of
those kinds some examples from my lab so
I mentioned that there is this
mutualistic antagonistic continuum and
that things can fall anywhere on this so
on this slide on the left side you have
a plant that's perhaps infected with a
mutualistic virus and it looks very
vigorous and you have the antagonistic
virus on the right side but they can
actually fall anywhere in between and
they can move as I said along that
continuum so symbiosis may occur at many
different levels of complexity between a
virus and its host and also among
viruses and mixed infections and then we
also look at symbiosis that occurs be
among viruses and their hosts and then
their host so so we look at fungi which
are often actually symbionts of plants
so we look at plants that are colonized
by fungi that are in turn infected with
viruses so why is it important to talk
about symbiosis well for one thing it
really stresses the relationships not
just the details of the individuals but
how they relate and interact with each
other and it gives us a nice framework
to look at non pathogenic or non
antagonistic lifestyles it can also
affect our evolutionary model so most
people are familiar
Darwinian evolution which is where like
entities compete and evolve gradually
through natural selection and this is a
very powerful force
however it's not necessarily the only
force in the evolution of life symbiotic
entities must cooperate so when Darwin
was developing his theory their
symbiosis wasn't even known and when
what people when people recognize that
they just thought it was some odd
bizarre thing and not common and so it
was never really taken into account in
Darwin's work and finally symbiosis is
also important because it leads to
symbiogenesis
which is speciation through fusion and
there's been a lot of that in virus host
interactions too but I'm not going to
talk about that today so we work on the
viruses of plants and fungi and all wild
plants are colonized by fungal and
bacterial symbionts even probably most
of the plants in your garden or your
yard in agriculture we do things to try
to get rid of fungi and bacteria but in
nature the plants are almost always
colonized by these microbes and well and
these microbes also Harbor viruses so my
lab studies these viruses of plants and
they're into fights and and one of the
reasons we've chosen this system is
because it's a nice system to work in
plants are easy to grow they're
inexpensive and you can get a lot of
genetically identical organisms in your
greenhouse and do actually reproducible
experiments so I'd like to move on to
some work we've done in the lab and I'm
going to talk a bit about plants and how
they adapt to extreme environment so
this picture is of Yellowstone National
Park this is taken in the winter so you
can see the steam rising off of some of
the hot springs and if you've been there
you may have seen a scene that looks
like this and what we have here is an
area where all the plants are dead or
most of them anyway and that's because
these geothermal features that make up
all the amazing things we see in
Yellowstone are actually not very stable
they move around a lot most of the ones
that you've seen as a tourist are the
most stable
they don't really like tourists to go
into the unstable area because it's
quite dangerous but you may see
something that looks like this and this
is not because of a forest fire but
because a geothermal feature moved so
for plants to survive they have to adapt
very rapidly and most plants don't
really survive very high temperatures on
vascular plants have one of the lower
upper limits of temperature of any
life-form but in Yellowstone you can
find this plant growing in geothermal
soils and this is growing here about 50
degrees centigrade so the temperatures
are in centigrade and this plant is
called by Cathy Liam Leonard on Olson or
hot springs panic grass and if this
plant is colonized by a fungus so the
way that this study was done this was
done by colleagues of mine and they
brought the plants into the laboratory
they surface sterilized them and then
they plated them on fungal growth media
and what happens is this fungus grows
out of this surface sterilized plant so
this is a fungal endophyte
it is living inside the plant this song
has happened to be curved you Larry Pro
to Baroda and what we see when we take
plants from an extreme environment is
that they usually just have one or very
few different fungi in them if you take
a plant from a relatively normal
environment you will probably see lots
of different kinds of fungi growing out
of it but if it's in an extreme
environment it usually just has one or
very few so Kirby Larry Crowe to brada
is a filamentous fungus it has these
spores that are curved with a little
protuberance that's where the name comes
from Kerrville area for to Bharata and
it's one of the few Latin names that
make sense to me because it's actually
named to describe the appearance of the
spores so this was an experiment that
was done more than 10 years ago by my
colleagues who was dark who originally
started this study and they grew the
plants the daikon thelia plants in the
in the laboratory the s on this slide
stands for symbiotic and the M s stands
for non symbiotic so the symbiotic
plants did just fine at 50 degrees and
even at
sixty-five degrees of soil temperature
whereas the non symbiotic plants didn't
do so well and at 65 degrees they all
died so this is where I got involved in
this study I was I had been studying
virus populations and plant viruses for
quite a while and I was interested in
looking at viruses that were that had a
persistent lifestyle that means that
they stayed in a single host for very
long periods of time many generations so
I asked my friends and colleagues if
they could send me their collection of
fungal isolates and they did so I looked
at them for viruses and the way that we
look for viruses and fungi the simplest
way is to look for double-stranded RNA
that's a hallmark feature of a virus and
this is a gel showing double-stranded
RNA that was extracted from a number of
different isolates from Yellowstone and
you can see there are two bands where
the arrow is there are two bands that
showed up in all of these isolates there
were some other things too but those two
were really consistent and when we
looked at the same fungus Kerrville area
but from other plants for example
strawberries shown here this plant does
not grow in the geothermal areas but
it's still colonized with Kerrville area
it turns out that there's no virus in
that so that seemed really interesting
to me and I wondered if the virus was
involved at all in this whole process so
well first we did what we did was
characterize the virus it's easy to
characterize the virus if you're a
biologist we knew how to do that so we
looked at it in the electron microscope
it's a small icosahedron virus it has um
two double-stranded RNAs we sequenced
those this was before a lot of the
next-generation sequencing was available
but still not too hard to sequence a
viral genome and we found that it
encoded v open reading frames this is
the genome organization as shown here
we know now that open reading frame 1
and 1a and 1b
may be expressed as a fusion protein and
in other isolates of this virus there is
a single open reading frame the 2 8 open
reading frame is the coat protein and we
don't know what the other open reading
frames do ok so
of course the question was is the virus
involved in thermal tolerance so in
order to look at that the first thing we
had to do was try to get rid of the
virus a cure the fungus of the virus and
that's actually quite difficult to do
these are persistent viruses for a
reason the name is for a reason they are
very persistent but eventually we
succeeded it was really an accident
which is how some of the best science
gets done so anyway eventually we got a
virus free isolate of the fungus and
then we introduced an antibiotic marker
into it so that we could track it so we
had this antibiotic or this virus free a
fungus containing a marker for hyper
myosin and then we reintroduced the
virus into that fungus and that we did
through a process called anastomosis
where you grow the the two different
strains of fungi in a petri dish and
where they come where they meet you get
things exchanged like viruses so in the
end we had three different strains of
the virus we had the wild-type which was
the original one from Yellowstone then
we had the virus free where we had cured
it and then we had what we called a n
where the fungus reacquired the virus
through this process of anastomosis so
here's the experiment that we did we and
we colonized the plants with the
wild-type fungus with Eva with the
fungus containing a and asta most virus
look of I was free fungus and then we
had non symbiotic plants so whenever we
had the virus that is in the wild-type
in the anastomosis fungus then the
plants survived these high soil
temperatures these were done at 55
degrees so they survived the high so
temperatures just fine and when we
didn't have the virus that means we had
the virus free fungus so the fungus was
still there but no virus those plants
behaved just like the ones that had no
fungus at all and they essentially they
all died alright so we've been doing a
little more ecology in this system now
in more recent times and this is a map
of the geothermal areas of Yellowstone
National Park and you may recognize some
of these if you visited
stone some of them are places that you
go to like Norris Geyser Basin and
Mammoth Hot Springs these are places
that people have like to visit in
they're really spectacular thing to see
too but if you won't want to do research
in Yellowstone then you can't really do
research in these popular tourist sites
they prefer the park prefers that no one
sees you collecting samples so they'd
like you to go far away from where the
tourists are and these are the areas
that we collected samples in so we have
five locations here amphitheater Springs
which is where we got the original
isolate then nymph Creek 100 Springs
Rabbit Creek and fire hole and with next
to these locations that are listed here
you can see how many samples we took not
very many and the reason we don't take
very many samples is that these are very
fragile environments so we don't want to
kill all the plants that are there by
taking them so we just take a very few
kind of a minimum number to see whether
we can figure out what's going on with
the ecology of the system so at the
amphitheater location we also collected
a number of different plant holes so
there we collected both the original
Panic grass dye kampilya Ladoga nelson
and then we also collected strawberry
which is for gary a-- we collected
cotton batting and bent grass another
monocot so we looked at all of these as
well well this is they all had into
fights in them basically they all had
crippled area in them and this is a
phylogenetic analysis of the endophyte
host that we collected from those sites
and this is a maximum like a good tree
we use the elongation factor when alpha
we've used a few other marker genes as
well and they the phylogeny holds up
very well so it turns out this large
group the larger clade here is crib you
Larry Pro - burrata and then we found a
second species of Kerrville area it
looks more like in a koala than any
other species but we actually think it's
it probably in new species
so this is on overlaying this with the
locations of where we collected these
and the point of this slide is really to
say that there isn't any Geographic
structure in the phylogeny of the fungal
endophyte so they're from all over from
all of the various places where we
collected we have more are from
amphitheater Springs just because we
collected a lot more from that site I
also want to point out that for triple
60 which is underlined was our initial
are our initial one and when we add on
the plant pulse we also don't see any
real structure in the phylogeny of the
endophytes based on the plant hosts so
we also found a lot of viruses so the
viruses here are shown in along side of
the phylogeny and all the plants that
are in red are plants that were thermal
tolerant though they grew they did very
well in high temperatures the endophytes
conferred this thermal tolerance and we
found a second virus in fact now we have
found a third virus they're all somewhat
related but they're not identical so
when we look at the phylogeny of the
viruses we see these two viruses are are
fairly distant in fact so this is again
a maximum likelihood treat this is using
the amino acid sequences of the RNA
dependent RNA polymerase and you can see
we also added a virus that we had
discovered in Oklahoma so it's in the
same group here and these are about 70
percent divergent so that sounds like a
lot if you're not used to looking at
virus viruses but actually it does put
them probably in the same family because
viruses have a much more diversity than
anything else all right so when we
looked at the curb Eulerian thermal
tolerance virus and this and the CD and
we compared them I should mention that
we named the second virus Cavalleria
virus too that's why it's OCD here very
clever with our naming scheme but anyway
um when we look at these two phylogeny
and you can see really good Congress
between the trees so all of the purview
Larry to Bharata
can the had the Kerbal area thermal
tolerance virus or I should say all the
Kerbal area thermal tolerance virus came
from Kirby Larry Foote to Bharata
whereas all the crew valerian virus too
came from the other species of Kerrville
area of course there is an exception
however and that is in each species of
Kerrville area we had one isolate that
was actually infected with both viruses
so that's the only non congruence in
these two trees so that only looked a
little more carefully at Kirby Larry
thermal tolerance virus and this is now
looking at the nucleotide sequences so
we get better resolution in these and
here we see that they're a significant
geographic structure in the end of
viruses so you can see that the ones
from amphitheater Springs grouped
together and they want this so from each
location they group together so this
tells us that the viruses are not
probably not moving around in this
larger area although the fungi are we
have again an exception here and that is
the Kerbal area thoroughly tolerance
virus that was found in the other
species of Cargill area it's also on a
different plant host so it's probably
been adapting to that new system that
new host so what we think is happening
is shown in this cartoon here so we
think that the virus so these hot spots
these geothermal features act a bit like
islands so you have on the first panel
you have the like geothermal site you
have the plant it's colonized with the
fungus that's infected with the virus
both the plant and the fungus can move
the seeds or in spores both can be
dispersed so they are not actually in
these geothermal soils they can be in
the cooler soils and when they're in the
cooler soil we don't find viruses so it
means there's some cost for the virus
they're having the virus so that when
you don't need it it disappears but if
these fungi and and or plants move again
into a geothermal site they have to
reacquire the virus and
from our data that's exactly what seems
to be happening so rather than carrying
the viruses with them they lose them and
then they reacquire them alright so I
want to move on now and tell you another
story about an extreme environment and
we're going to talk about plant viruses
here as mutualists so we started this
study we were using a plant virus vector
for silencing of drought-related genes
in plants so plant viruses have been
used as a way to express other genes in
their hosts for a long time and we do
that in plants as well as it's been done
in animals in MIT and in human systems
and so in this case we were using a
technique called silencing to look at
drought drought genes in plants and so
what you have here on the left is a
plant that's infected with tobacco
rattle virus which was the vector that
we used and then on the right you have
the plant that's infected with tobacco
rattle virus that's expressing part of a
gene called bag 2 these genes had been
described as being involved in stress
tolerance so indeed it looks like they
are so what we did with this experiment
was we just stopped watering the plants
it's a drought experiment it's very easy
to do and I do it all the time in my
house unfortunately I forget to water
the plants and then they go through this
drought stress but in this case the bag
suppressing the bag two genes made this
plants more sensitive to drought so that
was interesting but what turned out to
be more interesting was when we looked
at the control so these plants now that
are on your left those plants have no
virus at all and they are doing much
worse than anything else so we didn't
pursue looking at the bag two genes any
further and this was a few years ago
since then other people have looked at
this and published it but what we saw
here we thought was much more
interesting we saw that having tobacco
Ram virus in the plant made it very
drought tolerant these plants are a wild
species of tobacco called mikoshi on
avanthi gnyana they originated in
Australia and they are used by plant
biologists a lot because they are kind
of a universal host for plant viruses
so we decided to see what would happen
with other viruses that we had in the
lab but this is just a small collection
of viruses because we didn't work on a
huge array of them so this is broad
mosaic virus in the first set of panels
cucumber mosaic virus tobacco mosaic
virus and tobacco rattle virus these are
all on in mikoshi on avanthi Miyata the
wild tobacco and we use that as a host
because they all infect it so what you
have here are days after water
withdrawal and then you can see under
the the lock lane those are plants that
are not infected with the virus and then
when they have the virus and the
appearance of drought symptoms as well
as the occurrence of the wilted shoot
tip are both and delayed significantly
whenever you have a virus infection the
wilting of the shoot tip is especially
important because when the shoot tip
wilts the plant probably will not be
able to come back even if you water it
usually plants don't survive that kind
of stress all right so we found that all
the viruses we had in the lab at least
were able to confer this drought
tolerance to plants so then we looked at
cucumber mosaic virus and a lot of
different hosts because this virus has a
very broad host range so we looked at it
in some hosts that you're probably
familiar with like beets and pepper or
watermelon cucumber zucchini squash
tomato etc the solanum havoc I tease is
a wild relative of tomato from South
America and again in every case when we
have virus infection we have a delay in
the appearance of symptoms and we also
have it delay in the loading of the
shoot tip so these are just a few days
this doesn't seem maybe like a huge
amount of time but if you're a farmer
and you're waiting for it to rain this
could mean the difference between a crop
or not having a problem here's some
pictures of some of these plants so on
the left side we have rice plants
infected with grow mosaic virus and as
the drought experience experiment
continues the plants without the virus
become more and more
stress whereas the plants that are
virus-infected don't really change a
whole lot and on the right panel we have
a plant called kina podium and Miranda
color and that's another kina podium is
another genus of plants that are used a
lot in plant biology too because most
long viruses don't make a systemic
infection in these plants they only
infect little spots on the inoculated
leaf and they don't move systemically
and that's the case here so on the left
in that panel you have the uninfected
plants and on the right you have the CMV
infected plants so even though the virus
is not moving into the systemic tissue
it's still able to confer drought
tolerance and this is kind of in it
important also because kina podium you
might be more familiar with another
species called kina podium quinoa and
the same thing actually happens in that
plant and kina podium quinoa is the
plant that that produces quinoa a very
popular grain and growing that grain has
become more problematic in South America
where it's where it's a native because
of climate change so climate change has
changed the snowfall in the Andes
Mountains and the Altiplano region where
this is grown has much less water and so
drought stress is a significant issue so
it's possible that that farmers could
use viruses to attenuate that it
problems that they're facing due to
climate change another example of a
plant buyer is conferring tolerance to
stress as shown here so these plans
these are red beet plants the plants on
the Left again we're not inoculated with
virus and the ones on the right were
inoculated with virus and what we did
with these plants is we took them we put
them in a growth chamber and we drop the
temperature de Mol freezing at night so
during the day they were under so their
normal temperatures and then at night it
would drop down to below freezing and
what happened was the the uninfected
plants all died and the virus infected
plants actually did just fine so this is
also has some potential for practic
applications because if the if you were
to use if you had virus infected plants
you would be able to extend your growing
season a little bit so maybe at the
beginning of the growing season when you
might have a late frost or in the end of
the growing season when you might have
an early frost at night if you have
virus infected plants you could extend
that so I sometimes tell people well you
should infect your garden plants with
viruses and you'll have a better growing
season but there are sometimes prices to
be paid too so that's not always such a
great idea okay so what do we know about
plant viruses well in fact the first
vial was discovered and characterized
was tobacco mosaic virus in 1898 it was
the first virus and most plant viruses
like viruses of everything have been
largely described and characterized
because they cause disease so when one
of the other projects in my lab has been
to look at viruses in wild plants and
until recently these things were only
looked at in weeds surrounding crops but
virus discovery has really been aided by
next-generation sequencing were able to
obtain huge amounts of data now we're
still challenged with the bioinformatics
of sorting all that out but nevertheless
we've been able to look at plant viruses
from many different environments
including they've been looked at in
human and animal guts so you eat plants
so you have a lot of plant viruses in
your gut they're also found in water
sources within insects including
mosquitoes so we think of mosquitoes as
feeding on mammals but in fact the male
mosquitoes predominantly feed on plants
so this is a we did two studies in my
lap on the biodiversity of plant viruses
one was in the tall grass prairie
Preserve in Oklahoma and yeah and that's
an area that's managed by the Nature
Conservancy and the other was in the
area of conservation when accussed and
which is in northwestern Costa Rica so
the site in in Costa Rica is very
diverse there are many different
habitats there are many different
ecological zones
and there are a huge amount of
biodiversity of the host and in fact it
is a consid is about diversity hotspot
so about almost three percent of all the
world's species live in this very small
area which is less than smaller than the
average county in the United States so
there's a lot of diversity this is dry
forest which is deciduous in the dry
season there is primary dry forest here
some of the only primary dry forests
left it goes up into cloud forests
unfortunately because of climate change
cloud forests are becoming very rare
there are also geothermal areas here and
there are there is Atlantic rainforest
or Caribbean rainforest where you have
these enormous trees in the tall grass
prairie we have a single ecosystem grass
essentially there are a few areas of
trees in between but it's essentially
one ecosystem it's managed by the Nature
Conservancy by bison grazing so these
inventories we call them eco genomic
studies and I'll tell you why in a
minute we isolate totalement quick acid
from individual plants and this is
different than most meta genomic type of
studies because most metagenomic studies
take everything in a single environment
and we're taking individuals here so it
does make a difference it makes it a lot
more work but it also gives us a lot of
very different kind of data so we take
these we isolate these total nucleic
acids and then we enrich for
double-stranded RNA and that is a
hallmark of RNA virus infection and so
we are only looking at RNA viruses and
new studies this is converted to C DNA
we multiplex that we sequence it we
assemble it and then we match it to its
nearest relative by last searches and
most of what we find is new so we can
classify and my family if it's got an
it's related to a virus family but about
60% of what we have we find doesn't have
any similarity to any known virus family
we have now
analyzed or partially analyzed about
9,000 individual plants in these studies
and this is a summary of the virus
families we have found in these plants
and this organism not including the 60%
that don't have any hits and so what you
can see here you probably do suppose
won't have a lot of meaning to you but
what I want to point out is that a
number of these families are what are
known as persistent viruses so they're
shown this way and so you can see that
over half of these are actually Percy's
in these persistent virus families this
is a very different picture than what's
recognized in the international
committee for the taxonomy of viruses
because they only had lists about 24
different species there's a few more now
quite recently they've added a few more
but still are the majority of viruses
that are described by this group are
acute plant viruses not persistent
irises and I'll tell you a little bit
more about what that means in a second
here alright so in the wild plants many
can be Bend into existing virus families
as I said but not into existing general
or species and the majority are
persistent we have not seen any that are
causing any apparent disease so
persistent viruses are probably not the
viruses you've heard about acute plant
viruses they initiate an infection they
replicate usually quite rapidly they may
reach a very high titer they often cause
disease or death and they are always
resolved either by recovery of the plant
or by death or occasionally conversion
to chronic infections but chronic
infections in plants are not so common
persistent viruses actually infect the
host for very long periods of time
probably many generations and they are
passed along politically so there are
several families of plant viruses that
are persistent or sometimes they're
called cryptic but they're not really so
hidden so I prefer not to use that term
they have been very poorly studied in
general they are asymptomatic perhaps
that's one reason they haven't been
studied very much there
thought to be transmitted horizontally
only vertically and they don't move
between plant cells they just are moving
only by cell division so there are these
are the families of viruses and plants
that are persistent the top family in Si
and Donna Verde Tony Verde has not
really been officially recognized as a
plant virus the cry so very day recently
described the amount ability in the
party today so most likely we think
persistent viruses are mutualistic why
do we think that well they'd had this
very long association with their hosts
they're vertically transmitted and at
least one case we know they can provide
an important functional gene for a plant
and that is white clover cryptic virus
that virus can control modulation of the
of the plant so clover is a legume it
normally forms these nodules in a
symbiotic relationship with raisa
bacterium and the fixed nitrogen but
that's a costly thing for them to do so
if there's enough nitrogen in the soil
the virus can suppress the formation of
these nodules and that was they were
able to move this gene into another
plant and show that does the same thing
we also know from work in my lab and
others that bell pepper and Donna virus
and pepper cryptic virus both increased
the germination rates of peppers so in
the tall grass prairie we of 220 wild
plants that were carrying the partido
virus only six of those were co-infected
with an acute virus and given the
incidence of acute viruses we would have
expected many more six times as many of
the party B virus infected plants to be
Co infected and so we are currently in
my lab we are asking the question do
party new viruses protect plants from
the acute virus infection and we know in
the laboratory we have no problem
infecting plants that have party viruses
with other acute viruses as if they are
very easy to infect but we think it
might have something to do instead with
their interactions with the vectors of
plant viruses or insect effects so
insects are very
important in transmitting viruses and
plants and it turns out from quite
interesting recent work it's been shown
that when a virus infects a plant it it
affects the volatiles that the plant
produces so it can actually increase the
attraction of insects to the plant and
it can also produce anti feeding
compounds so once the insect has arrived
at the plant starts feeding on it it can
produce a compound that makes the insect
move off so it enhances its own
transmission this one so I'd like to UM
line up and we're going to have plenty
of time I think for questions so plant
and fungal viruses can help plants cope
with extreme environments and this could
be a really critical thing for feeding
the world in our changing climate so
it's something we really need to take
into consideration and wise biodiversity
study that studies have shown that plant
viruses are abundant and most of them
are asymptomatic so and persistent
viruses and plants are widespread and
they may have very important but is yet
undiscovered functions in plants one of
the things I also want to mention about
persistent viruses here is that they are
very very common in crop plants if you
eat peppers you eat persistent viruses
all the time but they're also very
common in many other plants and it's
interesting that during the
domestication of plants they were
selected for these they selected for
plants that carried these persistent
viruses so it makes me think that there
was something they conferred a trait to
the plant that was desirable for this
domestication process so these are the
kind of things that we are now exploring
in the lab to try to understand what's
going on so I want to leave you with
some images this is a picture in Costa
Rica where we've done these bad
adversity studies and you can see a very
beautiful lush seam here with lots of
plants and they all look really healthy
in fact in the wild plants we have not
seen anything that we could attribute to
viruses any kind of disease if you go a
few kilometers away from here to crop
plants in
we have on the upper piano we have
pineapple and on the lower panel we have
oranges and they look pretty diseased
and unhappy so what's the difference
between these well in the met in them
agriculture people have spent lots of
time and effort keeping all the microbes
out so that means bacteria fungi and
viruses viruses are usually kept out by
spraying for insects or by roving plants
that show symptoms so these plants are
probably pretty microbe free and they
don't look so good they do have some
microbes they probably have some
pathogenic microbes but in fact they're
beneficial microbes could perhaps help
them it another difference that's
important between this scene in the wild
and this scene of Agriculture is that in
agriculture we generally grow things in
a monoculture that can also have an
impact on the dynamics of disease so
this kind of a scenario is not unique to
Costa Rica this is also found in a
places like Africa this is a picture in
a wild area in Cote d'Ivoire and that
the very edge of this area is a field of
cassava which is devastated by cassava
mosaic virus so I'm going to end it
there and I just want to acknowledge my
own mutualistic Network my labs at Penn
State and the Noble Foundation the
Oklahoma plant virus biodiversity
working group and also rusty Rodriguez
and Regina Redmond who are mycologists
that I've worked with over the years and
also John Henson and then I also want to
acknowledge I'm Felicia Maria and my lab
in Costa Rica who did a lot of the work
isolating the double-stranded RNA out of
these wild plants and I want to
acknowledge the funding agencies and
before we start questions I just have a
couple of other things one I want to
mention that I just published a book on
viruses and and this is available now on
Amazon and I think you're going to see a
URL where you can connect to it so if
you're interested in
more about viruses this is a really fun
book and it's kind of a coffee-table
book it's just got a lot of pictures in
it it's very simple you can anyone can
read it and understand it and I will
leave you with a final image of this is
an insect in Costa Rica a praying mantis
and it's mimicking a plant so the back
of this insect looks like a plant but
what's really interesting to me is that
it's also mimicking a plant with
symptoms of virus infection so those
yellow spots are pretty common symptoms
that you might see in a virus infection
so perhaps this says that symptomatic
viruses have been with us for a long
time and with that I am ready to take
questions Marilyn thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question-and-answer
session I put my to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can okay
for our first question
Marilyn based on these traditional
definitions how would you classify human
non LTR retro pentas retrotransposons
Rivero centric solar eccentric I would
classify them as some as viruses or
ancient viruses that are and they that
were perhaps active viruses at one time
and now are just active in a different
way in the genome but I think they
probably originated as viruses
next question our plant pathologists
engage in viral transfection to produce
mutualistic environmental hardiness not
there's not a lot of there's not a lot
of work being done right now with that
although there are a couple of companies
that I'm aware of one in Seattle
Washington called applied symbiotic
technologies or perhaps its advanced
symbiotic technologies that they're
trying to use microbes in in a
beneficial way for agriculture and then
there's a company in Boston called
indigo which is also doing some similar
things so there is interest in using
microbes and including viruses although
viruses have not been explored as much
as bacteria and fungi for these purposes
so I think it's an important area for
people to look into there is a stigma
about viruses and I think that in order
to be successful with these kind of
inquiries we have to get past the stigma
of it one of the reasons I wrote this
book so I think that it's important to
you know open our minds up so they're
about ten years ago people thought all
bacteria were dangerous and bad and
pathogens and now people are recognizing
I mean even I think almost anybody will
recognize that there are lots of
beneficial microbes and bacteria in our
guts and we need them to survive and I
think that's true of viruses too so as
far as using viruses in agriculture
hasn't been done very much yet I will
say that there is there has been some
work done on using viruses as biocontrol
agents in agriculture in plants and
animals so viruses that infect bacteria
for example that are pathogens of
bacteria are being deployed to to get
rid of bacterial pathogens in plants
yeah next question why look only for D s
RNA many plant viruses are FX RNA virus
yeah that's true but in fact when you
look at double-stranded RNA you can find
the single-stranded RNA viruses too so
most single-stranded RNA viruses make
both strands during their replication
process and in fact we found a lot of
single-stranded RNA viruses in these
studies so they are detected as well the
only ones that you don't detect very
well are minus strand RNA viruses and we
saw some of those but not very many so
the reason for using this method is
because it gets rid of an awful lot of
the background that you would get if you
try to sequence all the RNA there are
other methods for doing these kind of
studies and the different people use
different methods I think they all have
drawbacks and they all have advantages
so it just depends on what you're
looking for how do you think the various
types of transpose and based elements in
plants impact the health of plants well
I can't claim to be an expert on
transposons
but there aren't indeed a lot of
transposons in plants and they do things
like they can affect gene expression I
guess the most famous ones are in corn
that affect the color variation and
there are some retro elements I wouldn't
call them retro transposon it's because
they don't probably don't jump around
anymore but there are retro elements in
some plants that can confer resistance
to related viruses so particularly the
para retroviruses and plants some of
them confer resistance to related
viruses other ones don't and there are
some para retroviruses that can jump
back out of the genome and become
infectious viruses too but transposons
themselves I don't really know they're a
very big part of the plant you know but
not just the plant you know and actually
there in other things to know Marilyn
are there any beneficial viruses and
humans
yes there are in fact there are quite a
few and there are other labs that have
worked on these so I'm not an expert in
names but there are for example I know
that in life there are herpes viruses
that are quite similar to herpes viruses
that humans can carry and these actually
protect against some bacterial
infections like the hedonic plague for
example Listeria which is a bacterial
disease that you can get from dairy
products so yes there are beneficial
viruses in humans and I think that
that's another area that hasn't been
very thoroughly explored but there are
quite a few and that and the other a lot
of these studies of course are done in
mice we don't do experiments in humans I
know there are really interesting
potentially beneficial virus in the gut
is neuro viruses so normal viruses are
kind of famous because some of them
caused a world gastrointestinal distress
like what you get on what they think
it's sometimes it's called cruise-ship
virus the virus that causes food
poisoning but there are other neural
viruses in mice that can actually
rebuild the gut architecture in a
sterile Mouse so the architecture of the
gut is very important in the immune
response and this is we've known for a
long time that well for quite a while
now they've known that this architecture
is at least in part built by the
bacteria that live in the gut but if you
have a sterile mouse which you can have
your own lice can be created by either
they're born and kept sterile or
sometimes you just treat them with
antibiotics and get rid of all of their
gut microbes and if you have a mouse
like that and you feed it on norovirus
it rebuilds that architecture that's so
critical for the immune system so
perhaps the viruses can actually replace
the bacteria in the gut for some of
these same kind of functions so there
are quite a few more there have been
some recent reviews I actually wrote one
myself but I'm not trying to advertise
too much but I
review last year in the Journal of
biology which was called move over
bacterial viruses make their mark as
beneficial microbes so that outlines
some of these examples as well thanks
why has there been such an overwhelming
emphasis on disease-causing viruses well
I'm not sure that there could be lots of
explanation so one thing is the first
virus that was discovered was causing
disease in plants tobacco plants tobacco
mosaic virus and so perhaps that set the
stage for disease-causing viruses I also
sometimes think that humans are obsessed
with bad news if you turn on the news
you rarely hear any good news
so perhaps we're all so obsessed with
bad viruses so that's another reason and
I guess finally I would say that perhaps
I mean we do know that that viruses can
cause very devastating diseases and so
people have been concerned about that
just for health risk health issues not
only in humans but in their domestic
plants and animals and sometimes in
wildlife too so I guess there's a reason
for that bias but I think it's important
to realize that those disease-causing
viruses are not the normal irises there
are the probably the exceptional viruses
thank you Thank You Marilyn we don't
have any more time for questions I would
like to once again thank dr. Marilyn
Ruth Inc for the presentation Marilee if
you have any final comments for our
audience
you know if you're interested in viruses
enjoy them there are a lot of fun and
there are amazing little microbes and
they can do a lot of amazing things so
if you're a young person getting into
research there's a lot of room to do
research in this area thank you very
much thanks for your attention thank you
again Marilyn want to remind our
audience that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
December 8 2016 you will receive an
email from lab Luce alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thanks
for joining us
see you next time device